Christian we want to ask you today
whether you would marry murder or
makeout with the following characters in
Game of Thrones
there are Hodor would you marry murder
or make out with oh sure
Theon Greyjoy and Gregor Clegane who
would you marry and who would you murder
and who'd you make out of sure Theon
Greyjoy
Gregor Clegane I'm gonna have to marry
either
I can't marry or sure so I obviously
have to either make out with an outfit
or beg or I go yeah go make out with
Alfie
I don't murder him yeah is it Greg yeah
nothing about might clear things up for
the future yeah get out of the way yes
it's gonna get him other way set the
lineup for Hodor yeah yeah yeah okay
Melisandre Loras Tyrell and Sandor
Clegane marry murder make house in
Melisandre Laura and Sandor Melisandre
she's a bit of a nasty piece of work
isn't she that one should be useful
marry her tree
yeah we playing the game right oh yeah
yeah yeah turian done Hail Caesar
this Loras Tyrell and Sandor Clegane
okay well makeover Loris cuz that
probably keep him happy and yeah what's
the murder
yeah well the two brothers something
here yeah hey debris slid if he the
title yeah right right final one
Margaery Tyrell Renly Baratheon and
Tywin Lannister marry murder make out so
Margaery Tyrell Renly Baratheon and
Tywin Lannister
okay well I'll make out with rambling
for the Illinois Loras I will marry
Charles dance from the I love here's the
119 see I don't care about her
yeah whatever yeah get rid of it off
with her head
yeah off with their heads sister
grabbers Chris United service
constituency